so yeah so today I'm gonna talk about
time series recycle urn people so what I
kind of mean by that is I talked about
timeseriesforecasting using like the
language of regular machine learning or
kind of conventional machine learning
and we're talking through some that code
and implementation for basically from
the framework of anybody who's familiar
and I'll dive into work just to give you
a little bit of background on who's
talking to you up here I actually
recently founded a company called
enhance AI where I focus on building a
product to help data scientists to
monitor the true performance of them
machine learning models once they if any
of you are dealing with that or just
want to vent to me about productionize
models I got the idea for this company
after spending a year doing data science
consulting here in New York building
full-stack products for companies also
random machine learning team and worked
as a data scientist at two different
retail startups here and I'm prior to
all that did a PhD in physics at
Columbia here in the city so a lot of
what I'm gonna talk about today kind of
was born from some blog posts that I
wrote as I was getting interested in
time series modeling so if you're
interested those are all on my website
and then typical places you can find me
online are either on Twitter or on so
just to kind of get us all grounded is
that we're using the same terminology
just wanted to give a very brief intro
to what is what is a time series so kind
of at the simplest standpoint it's
basically a number that depends on time
so kind of everything is a time series
of thing everything depends on time but
it's kind of standard standard types of
data that we deal with let's say more
obviously depend on time so as an
example Buber has like entire teams of
people that work on forecasting time
series and so for example something they
might want to do is forecast how many
trips are going to be taken on a given
day so they have historical data where
they know how many trips were taken on a
day a city and they might want to
forecast this you can imagine as a
company that loses
two dollars a year they won't want to
you know reduce the amount of money that
they're losing and so if you can
forecast you know how many trips will be
taken then you can make sure that you
have enough drivers available other big
companies deal with these types of
problems so Amazon has a nice paper on
the archive and where they talk about
predicting how many sales a product will
get in a given week and I've worked in
retail before and so I know that this is
a thing that companies have to do
because you have to buy your products
ahead of time and so if you overestimate
how many sales you expect to get this
can be bad because you don't sell all
these products and then all your money
is tied up cutting bought these products
that you can't sell so these are kind of
like big multi-million dollar
applications of time series modeling for
me I was focused on something much
simpler and kind of trivial we have a
bike share city here in New York which
is kind of one of because it's like a
legacy one it's not ductless like these
new ones instead we have these stations
and there's a finite number of docks
where you can dock a bike and I had this
issue at my last job where I would look
up online to see how many docks were
available at the station near my office
and I would say that there was some
docks available I'd ride my bike there
by the time I got there there'd be no
docks available and I have to you know
go find the next nearest station and so
it was a minor inconvenience but I was
like I should have been able to know
ahead of time that by the time that I
got to this station there would be no
docks available so a couple years ago I
set up a little system to start tracking
this data so the city bike has an API
where you can request from that API to
find out how many bikes are available
right now at every station and if you
set up something to continually request
then you can start to track this sort of
data and so this is a time series these
are the number of bikes that were at a
station near my old apartment where I
lived and you can see that there's like
a daily periodicity to this and in fact
if you look closely you can see that I
live near a commuter destination so I
was near Union Square and so there's a
lot of offices around there and so in
the morning
everybody would ride a bike to Union
Square and you can see that the number
of bikes at the station would rise and
basically max out until every dock was
full and then at the end of the day
everybody would take a bike and ride
home so this was kind of how I got
interested in this and we're gonna come
back to talking about the city bike data
but may before we get into that I kind
of want to tell you a little story of
how I ended up learning about time
series and so like many academics he
didn't know what they wanted to do after
grad school I spent my last year
wondering and decided alright I think
I'll do data science and so I studied a
whole bunch and one of the first classes
I took online was this machine learning
class by Andrew Inge which is fantastic
and it's free and I was going through
this class and learning about what is
machine learning and so in in a single
slide nutshell with machine learning we
have some target that we're trying to
predict so that's gonna be the Y in this
equation that's maybe it's the number of
bikes that are at a station maybe it's
whether a customer will purchase a
product you then have some model F where
you can put in some data that you know
that's this X matrix that's the these
are the features of your model this is
data that you know and then the goal is
to figure out the best parameters of
this model to be able to predict that
target and so that was all that was all
fine and good to me as a physicist
because I learned a lot about calculus
and I was like alright we can you know
take this function and minimize it and
everything else but the nice thing is
that nowadays we don't have to know math
anymore so we have scikit-learn we don't
have to know calculus because we have
auto differentiation libraries and it's
great so if I can't learn you can just
import a model let's say a linear
regression model and they they've kind
of distilled all of supervised learning
into this very simple API where you can
fit the model on some data so you pass
in your features the data that you know
and then the values that you're trying
to predict you fit the model to learn
the best parameters and then you can
take new data pass it in and create new
predictions and so that was kind of
really nice when I realized that
this existed and you don't have to code
it by hand but then I went to go look up
time series modeling and it was like
this whole nother world so there's all
these warning signs about make sure your
data is stationary and don't piss off
Gauss and Markov and everything else and
so it just it felt like something
completely different so I got to work
and started writing out these weird lag
matrices and all of this other crap that
you have to do but then you know I kind
of got so far away from machine learning
I was wondering how do I connect these
ideas and so one of the questions I was
asking myself was like how do I add
features to a time series like if I know
what the weather was like how do I use
that information
maybe to predict a time series better to
maybe you know predict how many bikes
will be available and so that was kind
of confusing to me the other thing was
that as I started working at a job and
actually starting to deploy code it
started to terrify me when I thought
about how would I actually deploy a time
series model so there's actually there's
lots of Python libraries for time series
modeling but oftentimes these libraries
the the data is kind of intimately
coupled with the model and the data
might even be like an attribute of the
model and so when I thought of how do I
deploy this where I taken this brand-new
data it gave me nightmares and so that's
where I kind of like set out on this
task to try to connect time series to
kind of conventional machine learning
and so the first question I wanted to
answer was you know if I want to try to
think of time series like I think of
scikit-learn stuff was like where's the
X matrix and the problem is that with
the time series there is no X matrix
there is only the why there's only at
least you know from simple standpoint
there's only the value that we're trying
to predict and so it felt kind of
confusing on what you're supposed to do
here
but it turns out that you can in fact
build out an X matrix and so one of the
simplest versions of time series
modelling is people create these things
called either auto regressive or lag
features and the idea which sounds like
you shouldn't be allowed to do this is
that you use the thing
that you're trying to predict to
actually create features to then predict
it but you make sure that what you're
doing is that you're never leaking the
future into the past and so what a lag
feature is is you define a window in
this case which we want to predict these
Y values and I've created a window size
of five and so what we're going to do is
we're gonna say let's use the previous
five values of the time series as
features in order to predict the next
value and so for let's say the five
right here
we're gonna use the previous five values
of the time series these will form the
features of my of my data and we'll try
to use these in order to predict this if
you have a single lag feature then this
is and I guess if you have no model then
this ends up being like a random walk
but the idea here is that yeah you
define a window and you just use these
previous values in order to predict and
in Python it's not so bad to do this you
write a for loop then you kind of apply
this moving window and so more visually
what this ends up being is that we can
take our time series and we can chunk it
up so every red point here is a value
that we're trying to predict and so each
of these red points this is kind of the
same time series stacked on top of
itself
you should these red points we can
extend them all along and form them into
the target array that we want to predict
and then we're always going to use the
previous values as our features and we
can kind of stack all of these blue
lines on top of each other and that will
give us our X matrix and so just to be
concrete about this typically when you
think of this X matrix or this feature
matrix or this design matrix each row is
a sample or an observation that you've
had and each column is is a different
feature that you're going to use and so
then each row of X corresponds to each
element of Y so one of the nice things
is that once you have an X matrix and
you've created your y array now you have
the entire world of scikit-learn at your
disposal so if you want you can import a
linear regression model and you can fit
that and
that is an ARIMA model just with the
autoregressive terms one thing actually
one call-out point that I'd like to add
here is that everything I'm going to
talk about in the framework of
scikit-learn it works for some parts of
time series modelling so it can work for
the auto regressive terms and the
integrated terms but you actually can't
create moving average terms if you're
familiar with that because that ends up
being a nonlinear PDE that you can't
solve with what scikit-learn but if
you're willing to throw out a little bit
of functionality then you gain a lot of
the functionality of scikit-learn
and so yeah you can throw a linear
regression model on but you can also
throw a random forests on if you want
why not
you can throw XT boost in there you can
find you know the latest fancy temporal
convolutional neural network if you want
and you can try to fit your data with
that now that you have created just this
X matrix and now that we've also created
the X matrix we can go back to answer my
original question of how do we add
features to this time series all you
have to do is you can just stack your
features next to those other features
that you've already built so if you
imagine that you have other features
like what is the weather like or what is
the state that the time series is in or
something like that or the city you can
just stack that information next to it
kind of horizontally concatenating it
I've made this look really easy here
probably the hardest thing and lots of
data science is dealing with time and so
it yeah if you can get your data to be
lined up perfectly with time right here
then it's easy to stack these features
in but often times one of the hardest
parts is reconstructing the state of
your system at the point in time that
this time series related to so I'll
leave that as an exercise to the reader
so now that we have you know done this
work to get our X matrix now we can
think through how we would want to
deploy this and so I was really excited
when I figured out how to create the X
matrix and that I could just throw
random forests on everything but there's
kind of a couple things that I've
glossed over here around how would we
actually deploy this so one of these is
that I talked about how you can build
out these flag features using the
previous values of the
time-series to predict the next value
but if you think about the earliest
values in the time series they don't
have any previous values or they don't
maybe don't have enough previous values
and so that doesn't really work well
with scikit-learn where you expect that
let's say your x matrix should have the
same number of rows as your as the
length of your y array and so you're
gonna have to figure out how are you
gonna handle this the other thing is
that often times people do
pre-processing on their time series so a
very popular one is you difference your
time series and so what that means is
you take each point in the time series
and you subtract the previous point from
it and so this is a way to kind of like
remove a slope from your data or remove
a trend it's actually kind of like a
numerical derivative and so but what
people often do is we they first
difference the data and then they fit a
model to the difference data and then
they need to understand so thinking
through how you end up doing this there
there's a little bit of functionality
recently that's psych and how this when
I first started this they didn't have
this functionality and so for that and a
couple other reasons I ended up building
this library called skits which is like
scikit-learn inspired time series models
and the goal is to make everything as
compatible as possible with scikit-learn
and so if you want to check it out it's
on my github it's pip installable and so
you all should be able to play along and
I have a bunch of blog posts where I
talk about using it and to be clear
there's a lot there's lots of other
Python libraries for site for time
series modeling some of which are
compatible scikit-learn
I a lot of what I did here was kind of
as an exercise in me learning learning
this stuff but I hope that it's useful
as well and I will follow up this or
towards the end of this talk I'll talk
about production izing this and so one
of the things that I set out to solve
was this this issue with these lag
features where you're missing them for
some stuff and so skits has an auto
regressive transformer which is a
subclass from scikit-learn z--
transformers and what it allows you to
do is define the number of lag features
that you'd like to use
and you can transform your data with it
so one thing to note here is that kind
of with anything in skits you just want
to make a copy of your data so let's say
I'm predicting this why I just make a
copy of it and make sure that it's it
has a column in it before transforming
it and what's gonna happen is that when
you pass it through this transformer we
make the stupid assumption that
everything is null in order to preserve
the shape and then you can later impute
these nulls if you would like and use
what like one of the in pewter and
scikit-learn as well with differencing
there is a differencing transformer and
so you can pass your data through the
difference transformer and it will
calculate the difference between
adjacent values of the time series so
for example the difference between five
and two is three and it'll also make
sure that that first value is a NAND
because there is no previous value but
then there's also this reversible in
pewter in there because I wanted to make
sure that I could get back to where I
started with everything and so first we
can impute this nan value to at least
fill it in with some number because you
typically need to pass numbers into
scikit-learn models but then the the
other key thing here is that if I want
to inverse transform like both of these
transformers then I get back to exactly
where I started and so what this allows
me to do is be able to generate
predictions like generate time series
forecasts on the exact same scale as the
as the data was originally in even if my
models are operating on some pre
processed version of the data okay so
we've been talking about transforming
data and things like that the next step
is how do we actually generate forecasts
how do we try to predict the future
this guy is a chief futurist in case you
didn't know so the standard way that
people do time series forecasting is
they use this thing called recursive
forecasting and so what you do is you
have your your data you feed it into
your model and you predict
next value in the time series and you
actually optimize your model to be able
to predict that next value so that's
that's really the optimization that's
occurring and then the way to predict
multiple values in the future maybe I
want to forecast the next week is I pass
that prediction back into my model and
then I go on and predict the next value
and I keep kind of passing it back in
and coming from like the machine
learning side of things this is kind of
crazy to me because we're directly
optimizing for that next step and then
we just hope that when we recursively
pass stuff through everything will be
okay and it seemed to me like we should
be directly optimizing for what we want
and if we want to predict the next ten
values then why don't we directly
optimize for that and so this is called
horizon forecasting and so you can
actually pass in the next three values
of the time series as your target and
you can directly optimize to be able to
predict all of them so it's kind of a
multi output regression is what this
ends up being called and so visually
what this ends up being if you remember
before we could kind of you know move
along and have this sliding window in
order to predict those next values
instead we can just predict the next
five if we want to and one thing I want
to call out here is that I've you know
I've been a bit glib in how I've
described recursive forecasting
typically people use like well-founded
statistical models when they build these
things and if you care about like the
uncertainty in your time series and
injecting domain expertise and causation
and correlation then oftentimes like
this stuff is somewhat guaranteed in
recursive forecasting because you've
designed these statistical models to
actually encapsulate how the behavior
should move along as you as you feed
data back in on the other hand if you're
willing to give some of that stuff up
and you're okay with things being a bit
more of a black box such as I just want
to predict the number of bikes somewhere
then you can take this more machine
learning driven approach and so skits
has a horizon transformer which you can
pass in the
get array which you're trying to predict
and it will go through that target and
generate the next however many targets
you would like to be able to predict and
so that's where you define the horizon
here and if you look it actually kind of
looks like the autoregressive
transformer but the idea here is that
you know you end up wanting to transform
your target such that you're predicting
multiple values in the future as opposed
to a single value so I don't want to go
too deep into this but kind of the last
step of all of this and what I wanted to
do to be able to deploy these things was
to group everything into a pipeline and
so if you're not familiar with
scikit-learn pipelines it allows you to
chain transformers together lots of
Transformers and then kind of throw an
estimator or a model on at the end in
order to encapsulate all of your logic
into one giant object and so skits has a
forecaster pipeline which is based off
of the site Cutler and pipeline one of
the things the forecaster pipeline does
is it allows you to operate on the
target
so everything typically everything in
scikit-learn all of your transformations
take place on the X matrix the design
matrix and you kind of have to leave the
the y array or the target alone the
forecaster pipeline knows what's going
on inside so it knows that when we want
to transform our horizon we only care
about the target that we're transforming
not the original data it also we can
make sure that certain Transformers only
operate on the target you can construct
a whole bunch of features and then you
can throw your model on the end and it
typically behaves like a typical
scikit-learn transfer pipeline you can
do forecasting with it so it has that
capability but you can also just
directly predict your your horizon yeah
and so kind of the other thing to point
out I don't really know this about
scikit-learn before I started doing this
but what's the linear regression you can
have a multi output that you predict so
like a multi output target and then
scikit-learn also has this nice thing
called a multi output regressor which
allows you to
train an individual model for every
target that you're trying to predict so
if I'm trying to predict the next 10
values in the time series and you have a
lot of compute and memory and time then
you can wrap any model you want in the
multi output regressor and it'll train
an individual model for every every
output throw XG boost in there and all
sorts other things so I have a whole
blog post where I talk about this but I
ended up kind of running this analysis
on some of the city bike data that I was
collecting and I tried out a linear
regression model an XG boost model and
then a fancy deep learning model and
like with most things XG boosts perform
the best linear regression was a lot
faster and so that's what I ended up
ended up designing and deploying so
let's get to the deployment stage I
mentioned how I collect this time series
I collected this time series of city
bike data
I've actually it's been collecting since
like 2016 I think I have like half a
billion rows of data or something like
that but the way this thing works is I
have a little lambda function on Amazon
that pings be like API every 2 minutes
it grabs you know how many bikes are at
every station in the city right now and
it writes that data to s3 there's an
another flask app that I have where I
have a little lambda function every 15
minutes that pings the flask app and
says hey start making some forecasts and
so the flask app has a thousand models
that I've trained for the thousand
stations that are in the city running on
this tiny little ec2 instance and then
PI data shout-out I have a little local
desk cluster that's running which allows
me to which allows the flask app to
submit a thousand forecasts to the task
cluster and each of these tasks we
generate a two hour forecast so in five
minute increments over the next two
hours how many bikes will be at every
station in the city and I actually built
this whole thing to stress test the
startup that I'm designing and so every
time I generate these forecasts I send
the forecast information to my system I
also send some historical data showing
how many bikes have been
at these stations of the previous two
hours it's all this it ended up being
pretty easy to deploy this whole thing
and I guess real quickly I will show you
a quick demo which maybe you all can see
so this is the city bike station near my
current apartment and so I was able to
track how is my model actually comparing
to the forecasted model and typically
when you're doing machine learning work
you kind of you know you create this
test set and you calculate some arrow
metrics on it and you get a single
number and you try to get that number or
smaller and so I had done this
originally when I was training these
models to try to see how they're
performing once I kind of got it into
this view where I could look at my
forecasts over time so this is a
one-hour ahead forecast so when I
predicted an hour from now how many
bikes will be there then how many bikes
were actually there I was disappointed
to see that in fact your your error is
not just a single number over time and
your error changes with time and so the
model ends up being pretty good at
predicting when nothing's gonna change
but probably when you want to predict
that things are gonna change I mean the
models okay but that's that's where you
tend to kind of see how the error
changes and I guess real quick shout out
a PI data shout-out is that all of this
I built using panel because I only know
how to program in Python and MATLAB and
nobody's gonna build a dashboard in
MATLAB but a panel is a great great very
new library for building interactive
dashboards and Python so just to wrap up
I have this library called skits it's on
my github I wrote a lot of blog posts
about all of this which should be easier
to get through than this fast talk and
thank you all for your time
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm happy to take any questions I
don't know so I had played with TS fresh
a little bit when I was looking into
these things but I don't recall exactly
how the API works for it and so that
would be something interesting to check
out so the question was around how how
to feature eyes the shape or trending
behavior so I think there's there's
different ways there is a trend
transformer within within skits which I
I'm trying to remember exactly what it
does but I think in in that scenario you
just learn an individual feature I think
for every element of the time series no
actually I don't quite remember so in
terms of shape and trend behavior I
think there's different ways to do it
for a features is kind of a nice way to
handle this in a more blackbox manner
where you can build out different
features that are related to different
frequencies that might exist within the
data there's been one
it's very welcome very surprised yeah I
it's largely just been me so far I
worked on this a lot last year and then
I've been busy with this this startup
and things like that but open source
contributions are very welcome I
recently ran black over all the code so
at least it's formatted nicely but yeah
everybody's welcome please please
contribute so
yeah so the question was around
differencing the data and making sure
that the differencing was enough to
actually make the data as stationary
yeah so sometimes people will difference
the data one time or two times and
there's actually this entire recipe
around how you should be doing this so I
kind of glossed over glossed over
stationarity here and kind of the reason
I glossed over it is that it took me a
while to figure out like why do things
need to be stationary so there's lots of
textbooks that will talk about this in
blog posts that talk about it and as far
as I could understand if you want to be
able to basically use statistical
guarantees to quantify the uncertainty
in your model or quantify correlation
then you need the data to be stationary
given the type of model that you're
using for generating the forecasts but
you can also not care about that so it's
it's fine if your data isn't stationary
in the sense that if if you just want
your model to be able to predict and as
far as you can tell the model predicts
based off of all of your offline and
online experiments then that's okay as
well and so I think yeah so there there
is kind of yeah there's the recipes to
make sure that a stationary and you can
do that but I guess it it's also it just
depends on what the what the application
is still looks exactly like this I
mainly been focused on building at the
startup side of things and I just needed
a forecast to be generated one thing I'd
like to do is track different types of
models so in my offline experiments I
found that you know XG boosts performed
better than a linear regression model
and so be interesting to be generating
multiple forecasts to see how these
behave
have you ever used the predictions oh
not yet I I recently got this up and
running I would like to create an API
where I can just ping ping my model to
see what is the forecast exactly right
now I've also been working from home and
so I don't really have the original
issue that I had a blessing and a curse
so with this it was literally just
autoregressive features that was it I
think so with the model that I ended up
building I just took a week so I think
it's sampled in 5-minute increments or
intervals and I took a whole week of
data as the feature and and I had
originally there's like seasonal
transformers and a bunch of other things
and skits and I originally tried all of
that and it turned out that just shoving
shoving a week of the previous values
through did decently enough yeah so I
think date dates would be particularly
interesting like Sunday's are very
different than Monday like Monday
morning is a very different day for
citibike data because people did not
commute the day before weather is
probably a huge one and then like
holidays the marathon yesterday things
like that
definitely not yeah so I originally
trained them all I trained all thousand
models on AWS batch and so and then they
all sit locally on the instance that I'm
running and I'm just using those models
and I haven't retrained them because I
actually kind of want to observe how the
models decay over time so yeah so yeah
you can and that was well yeah yeah so
you can do that with actually let me
think I don't know if I can put them die
I think you can put them actually in the
pipeline yes yes you can and so that way
everything that you're predicting is on
exact same scale because that's what
worried me even if you pre-process your
time series ahead of time like if you if
you normalize it right then then what
you end up predicting is on the
normalized time normalized scale as
opposed to the actual scale the data
where like the end user would be using
this forecasting
so I guess methods or applications okay
yeah I think basically low-risk time
series is it's probably the area where
you want this so you know if you're like
large-scale economic models that are
going to influence policy you might want
to make sure that these are more
statistically grounded than these more
machine learning a black box approaches
but I think often times and lots of
companies they just need something
that's better than an average I've
worked at lots of these companies where
you have people who have built at
averages and maybe they just use the
previous average as their future
prediction and they just want something
that's better than that and so if you
want to be able to quickly deploy these
things and just get people something
then I think oftentimes being able to do
it in this manner ends up being helpful
I will let you all go cuz I think it's
coffee break but thank you all